my name is beg Macbeth I was born bred
and educated and end up we moved on to
Menzies college on Monday and from my
high school years I enjoyed the
different opportunities given to me to
pursue my schooling and Trust the arts
leadership in the outdoors I chose to
get my degree of education at the
University of Otago and Vacaville campus
I am now our permanent staff member of
Gorman school where I take a delight for
class a new entrance I am proud to be
sponsored by the Soroptimist
International of Gore who hold many are
the same beliefs as I do and I strongly
believe the Goron district's area is an
ideal community for families to raise
children
on the plane Koreans I like going on the
train stars fast
providing children with an environment
to develop grow and learnin as a passion
of mine
people singing Goa has so many excellent
opportunities for family-friendly fun
like doing wheelies
what current rods are updating what is a
correct place for children and families
is right